TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
In Chrome 61 for
Android, we've launched
the navigator.share
method, which
allows web sites to invoke the
native sharing capabilities
of the host platform.
It's part of the
simple Web Share API
that allows you to easily
trigger the native Android
share dialog, passing either
a URL or text to share.
Code and screenshots are on the
post, linked in the description
below.
We recently introduced
the Mobile Web Specialist
Certification to
highlight developers
who have in-demand skills
as mobile web devs.
Follow the link and get
your digital badge today.
Based in Berlin, Zalando is
Europe's leading online fashion
platform.
With more than 70% of its
traffic now coming from mobile,
the company has invested
a lot in improving
the quality of its app to
provide a good user experience.
Using features like A/B
testing, the pre-launch report,
and the new release dashboard
from the Google Play Console,
Zalando saw a 6% increase in
installs and a 15% increase
in users' lifetime value.
Click through to the post for
the video with more details.
The holiday season is
right around the corner.
So we're rolling
out new reporting
to show how often your
shopping ad is in the top spot,
including product
status reporting
and absolute top
impressions shared.
Get started with the post.
TensorBoard is a suite
of visualizations
for inspecting and understanding
your TensorFlow models
and runs.
To allow the creation of new
and useful visualizations,
we recently made
available a consistent set
of APIs that allows you to
add custom visualization
plugins to TensorBoard.
Our hope is that
you use this API
to extend TensorBoard
and ensure that it covers
a wider variety of use cases.
Details, links, and
screenshots are on the post.
We recently announced a
Dedicated Interconnect,
which lets you establish
a private network
connection directly
to Google Cloud
Platform through one of
our Dedicated Interconnect
locations.
Dedicated Interconnect also
offers increased throughput
and even a potential
reduction in network costs.
For more details
and to get started,
head on over to the post.
A key feature of
Google Compute Engine
is managed instance
groups, which
allows you to manage collections
of identical instances
as a unit to quickly
deploy new VMs
and ensure they're
consistently configured.
We recently announced a new
managed instance group updater
to help you update your
Compute Engine via SMS
programmatically, and at scale.
Details and screenshots
are on the post, linked
in the description below.
Please like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for watching this week's
episode of "The Dev Show."
If you'd like to catch
some of our prior episodes,
they're right over here.